month ago you said I'm done with LA it's
a thin line between becoming more and
more common as City Soft on crimes mixed
with inflation create an on air that's
becoming insufferable for many residents
I was in LA with Kevin uh two months ago
and we went he took me out to a nice
restaurant we're having a conversation
I'm looking outside what was the hotel
we were talking about right across the
hotel uh uh SLS
there's a tree house homeless guy build
a treehouse director in Beverly Hills
wow how bad are things in LA right now
from your point of view you know what
it's again that's like where the media
is go read like The New York Times and
they'll tell you this is racist to talk
about but I have had more friends have
interactions with violent crime in the
last year and a half than in the
previous 30 years combined wow so my
ex-wife and my brother's ex-wife are on
the news running for their lives in
Beverly Hills from a shooting at El
pisteo on on Canon I had a friend of
mine with his eight-month pregnant wife
with a guy put a gun to her stomach at
the force right behind the Four Seasons
Hotel
um my ex-wife also grew up with someone
whose mother was killed in Beverly Hills
this year and uh if you remember that
guy just walked into her house in
Beverly Hills an 80 year old plus woman
and shot her
um so things are bad you know now I'm
not smart enough to want to get into all
of the stuff whether it's bail reform
whether it's the pandemic where whatever
it was was all I know is three years ago
it was a very different place and people
are fleeing at crazy rates and wealthy
people and no matter what anyone wants
to say about that it's going to cause
major problems because we already have
the highest taxes in the country and if
you take away all the high taxpayers
which look I don't make a dollar right
now so Conley pays nothing on this
podcast that I do so so I mean it's it's
not you know that's not my high concern
at this particular second my own taxes
but it's just getting really bad and you
know people don't feel safe you don't
want to drive a nice car you don't want
to wear your watch out and we go is this
going to become Venezuela is this like
what the plan is for this place and you
know
again I don't want to speak as if I'm
smart enough to understand these
politicians because I watch them they
they try to find their issues that they
can win on and then they go whether they
believe in anything they're saying I no
longer have any faith in that whatsoever
what is it at a point where obviously
musk left Rogan love a lot of people
have left that you you read about the
Austin people come in here people going
to Tennessee people are going to Nevada
some of the guys are going to Nevada
which as the Mark Wahlberg went to some
story came out about him leaving in
Nevada I think the story came out last
week who's the girl from Pretty Woman
Julia Roberts just left as well yeah and
she's going to a completely different
place but is it at a point where you're
thinking about leaving or no that's
where you're going to be for the rest of
your life because it's the business
you're in no 100 I'm thinking about
leaving I have a new show if it goes
it'll be in La
um I bought a house in the desert which
I understand isn't leaving California
but
um so I plan on spending a lot more time
out there
um but I'm right you got you got to go
in the cave and start writing yeah but
I've looked in Florida I've looked in
Nashville and I I've thought about it
which is sad because La has been a
really great place an Entourage you know
part of Entourage was a love letter to
LA and how much I love that place and
how I dreamed you know my parents didn't
let me go to UCLA because they they said
you'll never come home and so I dreamed
my entire life of being out in in
California in Hollywood and uh it's a
really beautiful place and you can never
ever replace that and you can never
replace the weather which you know when
I come here and I'm sweating at eight
o'clock in the morning you know I go
this is tough but welcome to Miami yeah
so but um I'm I'm seriously thinking
about leaving I'm having a I'm having a
baby so I cannot even comprehend right
now uh you know my my fiance walking
down the street with a baby right now
because it really does not feel safe so
and and you know again you're gonna have
you know jerkers like even Seth Rogen oh
that's part of life in the Big Cinema
you know getting your car stolen you
know what that's fine when you have 100
million dollars and you can just go this
but you know when you don't I just had I
had a flat tire it ruined the week of my
life I got stuck in the desert so I just
think that right now
um I'm hoping something turns it and
people start to to wake up you know
because it is the same thing I say about
Kanye it's like yeah we want to help
everybody with mental illness but we
can't allow lunatics to be running
around the streets yeah um because we
want to want to hear what their stories
are you know let me ask you
um because I'm the only one here that
hasn't spent a decade plus of their life
in La you spent how many years of your
life 24. 24. you're there for a decade
you're New York La guy I'm Miami Florida
born and raised
was it a slippery slope thing or did it
fall off the cliff and Avalanche style
since covet it fell off the cliff and
you know I mean you had to think there
were going to be some repercussions from
kovid I mean because of what was
happening and you know again for the
really rich people it seemed like oh
this is a great vacation but I have so
many friends who had businesses in La
that have been destroyed and you know it
never made sense to most of us and you
want to protect everyone that you can
but you know you just go what what was
the point of that and and it is it is a
it is a it's a tough pill to swallow and
I think we're gonna feel the effects of
this for a long long time let me ask you
a follow-up question because again born
and raised Miami like Florida has
catapulted to the top of everyone's list
since covid and you know a lot of people
will put DeSantis on a pedestal for what
he's done and I know you're saying I'm
not smart enough you're a pretty [ __ ]
smart guy
at some point is it sort of the policies
the politicians they kind of got to be
responsible for this nonsense you know
what whether it's Garcetti or Newsome
obviously obviously policies have to
have an effect but there are cyclical
situations that happen in markets in the
world like I said you know I got held up
at gunpoint in New York City in front of
the Plaza Hotel in 1990 some of the most
expensive real estate on the planet
Earth and there used to be prostitutes
standing right outside the Plaza Hotel
um those were the days great times but
New York New York was a scary scary
place the 70s which I wasn't really
around for were far worse
um so and then Giuliani cleaned it up he
did he really did and Bloomberg you know
and he did but you know it's such a it's
such a slippery slip because you can't
say [ __ ] without people saying you're
trying to Target this and that I just
want to Target criminals I want to get
them off the street I want to you know I
want to help people to try to have the
best lives they can have so you like
this Caruso guy that's running I do yeah
what do you like about them I I like
that he's a businessman who's
accomplished things I'm I'm so sick of
these [ __ ] politicians who've never
done anything and then you watch them
become rich as a politician they're
supposed to make 50 000 bucks a year and
work to try to make the world better but
they're really working for themselves so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
all right
[Music]